hello my name is an eco I'm a professor
of Finance at the singapore management
university and we just finished a great
session on the nexus between education
skills and jobs and this is part of the
east asian model for transforming the
global economy this is actually a
wonderful panel I had six different
people and the audience were very
engaged and we came away with very
important three thoughts number one
education in universities in ASEAN has
to work in collaboration with each other
because there are so many mismatch
between what the educators are producing
in terms of talent in a market and what
the industry needs across all the
different countries so the universities
have to work closely with each other the
universities have to work closely with
the industry and currently private
sector industry will need to invest in
talent very early both in terms of
talent development talent recruitment
and also engaging the young in the
future jobs of the world so what
essentially the journey has just begun
and we have to continue this
conversation both in the web platforms
and also privately in all the industries
that are represented by workers as well
as employers in the future